كوارث نوويه كثيره حول العالم نسمع عنها
بين حين واخر لكن من النادر ان نسمع عن
كارثه نوويه على ارض الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اربعه اشهر كامله اخفى فيها
المسؤولون الامريكيون سرا خطيرا يتعلق
باحدى محطاتها للطاقه النوويه لكنهم
اضطروا بعد ذلك الى الافصاح عما حدث بعد
ان فضح امرهم هنا ولايه مينيسوت الامريكيه
والتاريخ يشير الى 21 من نوفمبر عام 2022
نحو مليون ونصف المليون لتر من المياه
الملوثه بعناصر مشعه تسربت من محطه
النوويه التابعه لشركه على ضفاف نهر
المسيسافي التسرب حدث من انبوب ماء بين
مبنيين في المحطه والمياه المتسربه كانت
تحتوي على عنصر التريتيوم المشع
نظرا مشعا للهيدروجين وهو منتج ثانوي شائع
لعمليات المحطات النوويه التعرض الخارجي
لغاز الفتيوم او الماء المعالج به ليس
خطيرا للغايه لان يصدر جسيمات بيتا منخفضه
الطاقه ولا يستطيع الاشعاع اختراق الجلد
لكنه يشكل بعض المخاطر الصحيه اذا تم
تناوله او استنشاقه او دخوله الجسم من
خلال جرح مفتوح او حقنه
انها اخترت حكومه الولايات وكذلك لجنه
المراقبه النوويه الفيدراليه في اليوم
التالي لوقوع التسرب مؤكده ان المياه
المتسربه محتواه بالكامل في موقع المحطه
وانها استعادت 25% من الفيديو المسرب
واضافت ان المياه تحتوي على مستويات من
الكريتيوم اقل من عتبات السلامه الصادره
عن لجنه التنظيم النووي
اتخذنا خطوه سريعه على صعيد احتواء التسرب
في موقع المحطه الذي لم يتسبب في مخاطر
صحيه ولا اخرى تتعلق بالامان في المجتمع
او البيئه المحيطه
السلطات الامريكيه قالت انها انتظرت كل
تلك المده قبل الاعلان عن الحادثه للحصول
على مزيد من المعلومات حول التسرب مؤكده
ان المياه الجوفيه المشعه قد تجاوزت موقع
المحطه
بعد ان اصبحت لدينا جميع المعلومات حول
مكان حدوث التسرب وكميه تسرع بالمياه
الجوفيه وان المياه الجوفيه الملوثه قد
تجاوزت الحد الادنى قمنا بالاعلان عنها
حاله من الغضب اثارها اخفاء الحادثه عن
سكان في المنطقه وعدم الافصاح عنها الا
بعد مضي اربعه اشهر خصوصا ان اقرب بلده
ماهوله تبعد اقل من كيلومترين عن المحطه
لكن السلطات حاولت طمانه السكان مؤكده ان
مستويات الكيتو منخفضه في المياه المتسربه
ولا تشكل خطرا وان التلوث لم يصل الى نهر
الميسيسيبي القريب من الموقع لكن عمليه
التنظيف الكامل ربما ستستغرق شهورا